[Music]
you were on the wrong side of the road
you almost struck the curb numerous
times you're going 15 M yes you were
going 15 miles over the speed limit and
then when you made that leth hand turn
you almost ran off the road over here do
you seef yes hey how much you had to
drink
tonight one drink okay Olivia let me
have a fake ID please do not oliv please
do not not charge me with this Olivia
give me the fake Olivia give me the fake
ID thank you you've been what to jail
and I don't P what you to jail for I'm
concerned that you're operating a
vehicle in the State of Florida in the
County of Orange in the jurisdictional
limits of the University Central Florida
while you are your normal faculties are
impaired by a chemical controlled
substance
Olivia restrictions corre lenses not
valid for failure to pay traffic fine
29 she does have ch out of Florida with
officer safety for Batteries you run out
Miss
Miss off to the left with the right Miss
Nice look down at your
foot look down at your
foot
19 10 and 19 120 121 12 can you put your
thumbs like this what your thumbs okay
and then you're going to put like your
skin put it behind your back like that I
want you count to 30 for me
okay 5 6 7 8 9 all right 10 you are
under arrest for driving under the
influence of please don't please don't
please sir I beg of you I've been to
jail and I very bad TSD from jail
okay
Jesus they almost construct the car bad
yeah I saw
that my door open from back here yeah
should did I tell her
that huh did I say that to her yeah
okay
[Music]
how you doing good good my name is coral
PR police B you know why I'm stopping
tonight because I ran a bicycle cuz you
ran a
bicycle is that what he say I ran
right red light no so you were back on
uh Lake picket you were on the wrong
side of the road you almost struck the
curb numerous times you were going 15 M
yes you were going 15 mil over the speed
limit and then when you made that
left-hand turn you almost ran off the
road over here where are you coming from
tonight downtown downtown shift shift
where do you work at room 22 okay and
where you heading to right here you live
in night Circle yes you go to ECF yes
hey how much had to drink tonight one
drink what were you drinking tonight
vodka vodka okay how big was a vodka not
big at all not big at all all right drug
test me right now okay well I'm not
worried about drugs okay or breath okay
well that doesn't work that way okay so
let me have your vehicle registration
proof Insurance please
okay Delta 21 can I have a Delta 22 for
my RO
please
[Music]
this your current address here in
Orlando off at Indian Gap Drive yes sir
what's your name I would be a year okay
where's Indian Gap Drive Indian Gap
Drive is at samon and Gatlin Boulevard
okay right next to the
um right
next I've live there for about six
okay
okay Olivia let me has a fake
ID no the the one that was in your
[Applause]
purse
get that one let me have it please do
not please do not charge me with this
Olivia give me the F already been Olivia
give me the fake ID thank you you've
been what to jailing I don't pull on you
to jail for okay what you go to jail for
I don't need your credit cards following
too close you went to jail for following
too closely that's not an arrestable
offense so what I went there for it and
I'm really scared what were you charged
with Burg in AR conveyance when I was
just using self-defense and it was
dropped before it even made the State's
Attorney's office I don't I don't need
your credit cards what you need from me
uh to step out of the
vehicle okay come stand right at the
front of my car right
there Delta
21 Delta 21 signal one
investigation you have all right
Olivia what's in your hand okay we don't
need these I'm going to put these back
in your
car
unifor was just trying to home right
there at where I was supposed to use the
restroom and I really have to use the
restroom so whatever you need to do okay
so uh here's the thing I'm very
concerned that you shouldn't be
operating a vehicle I'm concerned that
you're operating a vehicle in the State
of Florida in the County of Orange in
the jurisdictional limits of the
University Central Florida why you are
your normal faculties are impaired by a
chemical controlled substance do you
have any problems participating in the
standardized field sobriety exercises
for me no sir are you the care of a
doctor of a dentist um no okay are you
diabetic or epileptic I am I have panic
disorder you have panic disorder okay do
you take medication for that yes what do
you take um I take a 5 mgram tablet and
I take a 10 migr tablet of
beum so you take 15 milligrams of that
one one drug 10 milligrams twice a day 5
milligrams
total twice a day morning you take two
five milligram tablets correct con
totaling 10 milligram okay is that the
only kind of prescription you're on and
the 5 milligram tablet of a like medical
how do I describe it um
muscular what's it for a muscular it's
for endometriosis for endometriosis okay
all right other than those two uh pills
are you on any other medications no no
sir okay um you have any physical
defects glass eyes artificial limbs
anything like that ITP what is ITP
idiopathic thrombos cytopenic Pera okay
can you tell me what that is can you
explain to me it's bruising disease
bruising easily which means
50,000 counts of platelets to 100,000
counts of platelets is a normal person's
range okay 150 to 200,000 is a normal
person's range okay so you just you
bruise very easily very easily okay and
I bleed very and you bleed very so uh
like are you in a blood thinners or
anything um no but I am prescribed stuff
to make me clot better if that makes
sense yes okay all right um other than
that any other kind of physical defects
or anything I need to know about Aderall
you're on Aderall when was the last time
you to
Aderall 4 or 5 p.m. today 15 milligram
15 milligram okay so besides the Aderall
and the other drug that you told me
about the other prescriptions there
anything else that you're taking red
red bu okay I understand that um do you
have any physical defects as far as like
anything your neck back legs arms knees
ankles anything that would prevent or
inhibit your completion of the exercises
no no okay very good all right here's
what I want you do put your feet
together put your arms down at your side
heels to heels toes to
toes okay can you see the tip of my pen
right here what I want you to do is
follow tip of my pen Your Eyes Only and
don't move your head do you
understand yes
okay
don't anticipate where's going to go
just follow your
eyes
you got you got to follow your eyes
okay don't don't move your head just
your
eyes
don't don't move your head do me a favor
take your take your hands go like this
make like a cup like it put them around
your chin like this there you go okay
now and put your hands against your
there you go
okay
clear Olivia deal not valid restrictions
correct not valid for failure to pay
traffic fine
29 she does have ch out of Florida with
officer safety for battery she is a
current student we she everything she's
saying it's right all right a
contacts
okay all
right St back we're gonna we're going to
step right over there to the by the
clubhouse right there
okay keep walking we're just going to go
right by right in those parking space is
right
there all right see this white line
that's right in front of us yes okay
here's what I want you to do want you st
right on that white line for me okay
perfect just like that for are you
comfortable doing this in your shoes or
you need to take your sandals off I'm
fine okay if you want to kind of hang
onto your dress a little bit I don't
want you to trip over it okay here's
what I want you to do see how this line
is flat level free debris and well
lit yes okay what I want you to do is
put your left foot on the line put your
right foot in front of your left heels
touching your
toes heels touching your toes arms down
by your side and don't move from that
position until I tell you to do you
understand do do you understand okay
what I tell you to you're going to take
a series of nine steps walking down the
line you're going to touch Heel To Toe
on every step you're going to look down
at your feet you're going to count each
step out loud you're going to leave your
arms to your side any questions so far
no okay after the ninth step you're
going to turn around and here's how
you're going to do that you're going to
leave your front foot the heels heels
and Toes got a
touch okay you're going to turn around
here's how you can do that you're going
to leave your front foot on the line
your back foot's going to come also what
say no okay your front foot's going to
stand on the line your back foot's going
to come off the line take a series of
small steps and return down the line in
the same manner nine Heel To Toe steps
look down at your feet count each step
out loud and leave your arms to your
side once you begin walking do not stop
until you've completed everything do you
understand I'm going to demonstrate for
you stay just like that for me okay can
you see my feet yes a little like this
one two three all the way to nine on
that ninth step front foot stays on the
line back foot comes off the line series
of small steps and we return on the line
in the same manner one two three all the
way to nine do you understand all those
instructions do you have any questions
for me do you need me to repeat anything
for
you okay you may
begin arms
M pivot miss miss
miss off to the left with the right miss
miss miss arms okay here's the next
thing want you do face me feet together
arms down your side heels to heels toes
to toes in a moment what you're going to
do is you're going to raise one leg
either leg approximately six inches off
the ground where your foot pointed out
so it's parallel to the ground while
holding that position you're going to
count it loud in the following manner
1,1 1,002 13 and so on until I tell you
to stop eyes on your elevated foot arms
to your side if you happen to put your
foot down for any reason reason pick it
back up and keep counting where you left
off do you understand those instructions
yes do you need me to repeat anything
for you no
okay you can go ahead and
begin look down at your
foot look down at your
foot7
10089 2012 20133 2014 2015 2016
1789 10 and 19 120 121
1223 okay I got one more thing I want
you to do for me okay can you see that
tree right there yes okay here's what I
want you do face tree spread your feet
okay nice and wide okay can you put your
thumbs like this what your thumbs okay
and then you're going to put like your
skin put it behind your back like that I
want you count to 30 for me okay start
counting to
30 four 5 6
78 9 all right 10 you are under arrest
for driving under the influence of the
chemical control substance I'm sorry
what you are under arrest for du please
don't please don't please sir I beg of
you I'm not drunk I will do a braler
test I will do anything you guys in
front of you okay come step over
here you back
we're to go to that back car right there
I've been to jail and I very bad TSD
from jail okay I just want to let you
know well I appreciate it letting me
know okay so first thing we're going to
go is to the duy center yes
sir are you I live oh I was I was oh you
want oh just do a I'll do the I'll do
the uh are you good with it I can take
her yeah I don't care oh okay I'll I'll
get your draw at and the and the stuff
okay oh okay that's need to go down
there first are you going to take me
home they got one no you're going to go
actually this car please don't take me
to
the okay I will do anything I can you
want to Pro to you that I
not I I don't operate influence okay
well I will do anything I don't drink
under the job I literally you can breath
fize me right now well at the duy center
where where you're going to go to you'll
have an opportunity to take a breath
test okay so this officer is going to
take us to give you all right just face
car real quick you have anything else on
you no but I have to be really bad in my
Liv in this apartment
your do I have to go all the way to
Millennia yes down that way please no
listen we don't have a choice you're
you're I didn't I didn't
drink
c um let me get your D and a
ticket I don't know how to work an
iPhone but her directions are still
going
so here's your phone yeah that works and
by the time you get down there you'll
still get out of here you know give me
just two
minutes
four five six 7 8 9 all right 10 you are
under arrest for driving Under the
Influence I'm sorry what you under
arrest please don't please don't please
don't please sir I beg of
you I am not drunk I will do a
breathalyzer test I will do anything you
guys need me to right now in front of
you okay step over here
[Applause]
right here
Frank is this you want to take
[Applause]
her yeah are you I live right here oh
you want oh I'll do I'll do the uh are
you good with it I can take her yeah I
don't care oh okay I'll I'll get your
drawer at and the and the stuff okay oh
okay unless you need to go down there
for are you going to take me home no
you're going to go actually this
car well I will do anything I don't
drink under the job I literally you can
brezee me right now okay well at dii
Center where where you're going to go to
you'll have an opportunity to take a
breath test okay so this officer is
going to take custody of you all right
just face the car real quick you have
anything else on you no but I have to PE
really bad and I live in this apartment
spr your Fe real
quick so I have to go all the way to
Millennium yes down that
Way's the
car I did
I
[Music]